good morning Hank it's Monday I'm raking
today so Hank several years ago my
writer friend David Levithan and I
started writing a book together and
today hopefully I'm going to find out if
it's going to be published and by whom
and for how much and the answers to
other interesting questions so what I'm
gonna try to do is just to share the
experience of today with you
mostly it's gonna be me on this phone
hey how are you yeah I'm nervous man
it's a long day it's been a long day
today I threw up in my mouth a little
earlier Hank the thing about this book
and by the way I'm on my way to the
doctor's office and my vlogging while
driving is not an endorsement of
vlogging while drive and usually you
know like about what's going to happen
but in this particular situation I
really genuinely have no idea of what's
going to happen like at any moment my
agent could call me and she could be
like sorry John all your dreams are dead
basically Hank has a rule I like
situations where the number of
possibilities is finite enough that I
can think about all of them and puzzle
through how I'm going to feel about all
of them in advance and in this situation
there are just too many possible
outcomes for me to have any idea how I'm
going to be feeling later this afternoon
not to mention the fact that god only
knows what the doctors gonna say Hank
I'm finished at the doctor's office
still no call I don't want to get into
the details of what happened to me at
the doctor's office but suffice it to
say that I was wearing a gown and I
don't like to be touched there on the
upside I'm okay why won't you ring ring
ring hello hi how are you oh my god
seriously Wow
this is so much better than the part of
my day when the doctor was giving me a
prostate exam this is so much better
than that was David Levithan I'm
speaking to both to you and to the
viewers of Brotherhood 2.0 and my
brother Hank David says hi oh my gosh
can you believe it are you really happy
another day I'll start to worry about
how they're good sell this book but
today all I have to worry about is where
I'm gonna get my champagne yes Hank hope
everything's going well for you I'll see
you tomorrow
PS sorry nerdfighters but there's no
scavenger hunt clue today the scavenger
hunt will return soon but in the
meantime I wanted to thank everyone who
helped free Hank from his kidnappers